welcome to Conan O'Brien needs a friend
joined as always by my uh steady
compatriots
Sonoma session my assistant who
does little or nothing for me and uh
Matt Gourley you do a great job Matt by
the way I hate to draw a wedge between
the two of you but yes you love that
yeah thank you and I won't accept that
until you compliment my friend son of
obsessing Sona you're very good being
famous for doing nothing you've written
a book about it accept it yeah uh I mean
he's not wrong yeah yeah but it just
it's do the Picasso of screwing around I
I am very good at it I've been good at
it my whole life but I think when you
start off like that and then go to Matt
and say oh you're great oh he's Nails it
stings okay Nails it now the Picasso of
nail in it exactly
um you know it was fun is uh we just
before we were recording there's guitars
in the studio today and uh so I picked
up an acoustic and started screwing
around with it and then uh you picked up
an acoustic uh Matt and started playing
and it was kind of fun and we never do
that and never play together uh and
I started joking around that it would be
amusing to me if suddenly the format of
this show
changed to you and I playing kind of
mediocre to okay accused acoustic Duos
together and Sona just quietly listening
yeah and um which still would still book
great guests and they would come and
they'd be out in the hallway but we
wouldn't ever bring them in and it would
you you and I just doing this stuff and
then of course uh our our Overlord Adam
sacks would keep coming to us and saying
uh guys
the numbers are really the downloads are
just tanking and we're like hey man
we're just we're making some great music
together and we're just really enjoying
the Vibes that's you talking that's me
talking after a couple of uh it's a
helium changed you know some helium and
uh a mixture of helium and sweet sweet
Mary Chain
[Laughter]
but uh but you and I just noodling and
then you'd be like oh yeah here's one
from uh you know Amy what you gonna do
and we're just playing and
and we were doing that kind of stuff and
people were really getting turned off by
it but you and I were having a good time
how long would this last before a day
well Adam jump in here Adam I want your
actual opinion of when how quickly would
we be shut down as a podcast and be
honest I think the first few episodes
the numbers would probably be okay
people just because people joke yeah I
understand and then by episode four or
five people would start to say oh I
guess this is what the show is now I'm
not interested anymore yeah thank you I
was generous that was episode four or
five yeah and also that they're just
like I'm not interested anymore rather
than [ __ ] this yeah right [ __ ] this [ __ ]
violently
um also keep in mind we're Stu insist
that we still book because we get
amazing guests yeah and would still
people would say like you know
um you know whatever who who oh well you
like the Tom Hanks yeah Tom Hanks is
here and he's out he's outside because
he we booked him and he's ready to talk
and he's got some funny stories he wants
I guess technically we could still put
Tom hanks's name on the episode yes
exactly I'm still saying like our guest
today is Tom Hanks he's out there we'll
get to him in a second
um
what was your song Hey me what you gonna
do I think that I could be weird
I would love it if there was a musician
a really well-known musician who wants
to join you guys right
oh we don't let him in no so James James
Taylor yes James Taylor is in the
hallway he's been booked and here's Matt
and I playing and he's like oh well you
know they're as ant for amateurs they're
okay I'd love to go in and help them
we're like we got it good why don't you
run along Mr Fire and Rain thanks a lot
Sweet Baby James
Carly Simon single yeah
but I just love that um and then Adam
occasionally like um I think Tom Hanks
is about to leave we're like let him go
we don't need him
so the hill you're gonna die and then
I'm yeah and then I'm just like man why
don't you just start us out and see and
uh and I'll do some finger picking and
then it'll be kind of a blues
progression and you're like uh yeah uh
Tom just got in his car and he's leaving
he's looked pissed and I you never see
Tom Hanks piss but he's pissed yeah yeah
and then you're like well a man you know
and this is these are original songs
they're not even some people no you can
clear the Music
These are original songs these are
highly Originals original yeah if that
the Amy ones I've never that's a uh no I
was I was sort of riffing off of um the
famous song Amy by
Amy what you wanna do I think I can be
with you for a while maybe longer if I
do that's quite a well-known you're
famous I don't know that song yeah
that's a quite famous song
don't angry me
there's a couple days
I can't believe no one knows this song I
do I think I'm shocked Matt doesn't know
maybe I'll know it when I hear the real
version yeah I mean look I'm not
did I say I think it's by the is it by
the pure prayer yes Pure Prairie League
all right
oh yeah exactly and what did you say I
said is it Amy right and I said don't
anger me because obviously
Eduardo oh no so guess what chalk up
another one O'Brien
Eduardo wow
when you said Amy I was like uh yeah
Eduardo oh boy
God I'm never wrong I'm with Conan
because if it was spelled that way the
song would go Aim
so just just wait a second think about
it
foreign
[Music]
this is the kind of music we'd be
playing yeah for sure it's like skiffle
folk yeah yeah so I'm going to get you
to the chorus
God no one can spell around here here we
go and I named it
never heard this
oh yes I've never heard it you've never
heard the song I've never heard this
song in my whole life stay with you
okay it's all right okay yeah
yeah this is okay it's listen Pure
Prairie League that's the kind of music
that you and I are gonna play
it's real hip
real hip 1972 music okay yeah I can't
tell if you're being sarcastic I'm being
very sarcastic I still can't tell it's
not even it's not even 70s music
everyone's heard no no but my point is
that's the kind of music that gorley and
I would really dig down into we'd make
our own versions of it you know ho
Cynthia
you always were my girl oh Cynthia I
think of you as my pal that's my pal
when will you lay me down in bed
well that is that is that someone who's
in firm yeah I got someone who uh-huh
would you please carry me to the toilet
would you please lay me on the ball my
legs
and I'm afraid that kind of song
shooting out my guts is my goal yeah
there you go yeah see you and I are the
Lennon and McCartney of awful something
yeah a terrible thing but I think you
mean Vladimir Lenin yes and um yeah uh
Linda McCartney
always defend Linda McCartney I love
that woman
what I'm saying is
um that's the kind of music it'll be all
originals and we would do that book big
guests and they would leave now Adam how
soon before the big guests stopped
showing up when word gets around town
that
Hanks showed up it was turned away
because we were playing our shitty music
um you know James Taylor was turned away
from joining us they showed up to
promote something and to talk and they
didn't get on the air how soon would
would the word get out oh instantly in
the podcast community and you think that
would be a negative for us in terms of
booking future people it would we'd have
to talk to Paula and Gina and the other
Bookers but I think it would happen very
quickly the publicist really live show
where we announced the guest and the
guest shows up but Conan and I just play
on stage and the guest never comes on
stage and they can leave whenever they
want to leave but once they go in that
room technically they were there for the
show yeah yeah their name is going on
yeah the name's on the Marquis yeah and
the name's going on the title of the
podcast I think what uh Adam is saying
and I I don't disagree my guess is once
we uh continuously uh evict top talent
from our show without letting him speak
word would get out I think we'd never
know until we do a year of this no wait
where am I what am I doing
sitting you're sitting and you you'd
contractually have to not like manage to
actually have happened
because they have to not and sort of be
like and occasionally you'd have to say
man you guys are in a good group no yes
hard pass yeah no ways if you erase if
you say it no honestly there's not
enough money in
other words every time you say you guys
you guys are in a really good job
you're a seller and guess what you just
lost a sweet gig to Eduardo okay this
game is played and that 175 comes out of
your paycheck exactly freezer pay yes
right praise her pay praise or pay which
is our next song let's go into it you've
got to praise our pay
um yeah I uh I love this
look I don't think we're gonna do this
because I love the format we have yeah
but I do have a sickness which is I
always think of and we've I think we've
talked about this what's the worst thing
I could do yeah and uh
this is really up there yeah we have a
nice thing going here with this podcast
this would tank it really quickly that
would